a gritty violent take of one of DC
Comics most infamous and instantly
recognizable characters Joker was all
anyone could talk about in the fall of
2019
how did Joaquin Phoenix prepare for his
role as Arthur Fleck the mentally
unstable aspiring comedian who snaps and
becomes a mouthpiece for Gotham's
disenfranchised would Phoenix's
portrayal of the man who called himself
the Joker be better or worse than the
lates Heath Ledger's is there a
possibility for a Joker sequel what
didn't viewers get to see on screen know
that last question is arguably the most
intriguing to chew upon as there are a
number of scenes that didn't make it
into the theatrical version of Joker but
unlike what the vast majority of studios
and creatives do of their films Warner
Brothers and director Todd Phillips have
no intentions to release any of Joker's
deleted scenes so put it plainly Joker
director Todd Phillips just straight-up
hates deleted scenes he owned up to that
fact in conversation with collider
telling the outlet that he has an
aversion to releasing deleted scenes to
the public as he feels whatever makes it
to the big screen should be the only cut
of a film audiences ever see - whether
four scenes were a mood from Joker or if
they were simply trimmed down in the
editing Bay Phillips revealed that there
are quote
plenty of deleted scenes but they're not
going to be on the DVD
he continued I don't do deleted scenes
deleted scenes of deleted for a reason I
have a thing against extended cuts and I
kind of hate deleted scenes the movie
that exists is exactly the movie we want
it to be I feel like all that adding
deleted scenes do is confuse it though
Phillips and Phoenix built a strong
rapport while shooting Joker they almost
had a disagreement over a scene that was
ultimately cut from the film as Phoenix
told Collider there was a scene he loved
that Phillips eventually wants a gun one
that takes place inside the stairwell at
haha' the clown for hire company for
which Arthur works according to Phillips
our scene was quote a heartbreaker and
one of the last ones cut out of the film
it saw Arthur and his coworker Randall
whom if you're a call Arthur eventually
dispatches violently with a pair of
scissors talking on the stairwell
leading up to the hahas officers
ultimately Phoenix agree with Phillips's
analysis and realized the moments needed
to be tossed to make Joker the best it
could be
Phoenix dished I'd always really liked
the scene and Todd told me and said
we're cutting that scene else and at
first I thought like wait a minute what
do you
you have cut that scene out and then of
course I saw it and it was very obvious
it has to go that's just what's so cool
about movies right you can have a great
scene it's something that makes sense
but the movie is a collection of all
these scenes and they have to work
together to tell the story that delete
the Joker scene may have been rather
inconsequential in the grand scheme of
things but there was one sequence left
out of the film that would have altered
audience's understanding of the
narrative in a profound way in an
interview of indieWIRE in november 20
1948 from joker a scene that confirmed
the fate of sassy beat character sophie
the imagine the love interest of Arthur
Fleck I was hoping you'd come in and rob
the place come by tomorrow at the end of
the film
Arthur is seen leaving Sophie's
apartment following the revelation that
he's made up in his head their entire
relationship the camera shows Arthur
walking down the hallway causing fans to
question whether he'd killed Sophie
Phillips explained that there was a
later scene that found Sophie watching
Arthur's infamous interview with
talk-show hosts Marie Franklin which
would have confirmed she was still alive
and the Arthur certainly didn't kill her
according to indie wire Phillips removed
that scene because it quotes would have
disrupted the film's narrative structure
which the director wanted to be angled
completely from Arthur's perspective
perhaps it's a good thing the fans won't
ever get to feast their eyes on any
Scrubs Joker seen the film in the way
audiences know it now a billion dollar
earning oscar-nominated psychological
thriller that transcends the bounds of
comic book adaptations may be best left
and changed by the release of what was
for good reason removed prior to its
release the less we know the better
that's the real joke do you want to tell
it to me
[Music]
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos but
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]